I'll Roden you often talk about scams
what about traps that people often fall
into in life okay here's a few you
there's really a lot of these right but
there's really a few that I see come up
a lot the sunk cost fallacy a lot of
people day to day become prey to the
trap of the sunk cost fallacy and an
example of this would be you go to a
movie you buy the ticket and the movie
starts and the movies a disaster you're
having a miserable time there are people
who would say I paid for the ticket so I
might as well stay so I don't lose out
on the entertainment I paid for that's
the sunk cost fallacy because if doing
anything else even nothing at all would
bring you more enjoyment than the rest
of the movie you've spent the money it's
a sunk cost
you should still leave the movie early
that's just an example right and I think
it applies to people a lot of times in
relationships I've invested a lot of
time in this relationship I might as
well stay in it
when the reality is maybe getting out of
the relationship is actually the right
decision the fact that you've already
invested this time doesn't matter
because you can't get it back well I
think maybe you try to convince yourself
that it could get better like that
crappy movie you know maybe it has a
slow start but it could turn around and
there's a plot twist and it's fantastic
well you can rebel in your relationship
you know maybe you can solve them and
work forward job is another example
exact same thing this job is a disaster
but I'm here I'm close to my next
promotion and I should stick it out and
yeah maybe it will get better but maybe
it won't so sunk cost fallacy doesn't
always apply important thing to know
about hedonic adaptation okay Pat's
confused Pat looks scared right now
hedonic adaptation this is basically
where you get humans get accustomed to
new circumstances very quickly and
hedonic adaptation is used a lot in
personal finance writing to explain what
happens when you earn more money and
then you immediately start spending more
money on your lifestyle because you say
hey I've got more money now buying more
stuff or living in a life of more luxury
is going to make me enjoy life more
and then that becomes your new baseline
so over the long term the only way to
actually get more enjoyment is by
constantly buying more and more
expensive stuff and living a life of
more and more luxury when the truth is
you're going to get adjusted to whatever
it is that you do in life in terms of
increasing your level of luxury or
spending this happens with cars this
happens houses whatever that becomes
your new baseline and it will no longer
bring you any more enjoyment than your
initial standard of living of course
this doesn't apply to people who are in
poverty people who are lacking basic
resources right I'm not talking about
that and if a lot of people understood
that from the beginning they'd save a
lot more money and really skip a sort of
a lot of grief that often happens do you
know people who do this where every time
they get a new job making more money
they immediately buy a new big-screen TV
get a more expensive apartment and a
more expensive car but then a year later
they don't actually seem to be
particularly happy what happier goes to
a basic idea of that money can't buy
happiness now I also think it also Peaks
out at a certain point it does you know
just making more and more money won't
necessarily make you happy absolutely
studies as to what the perfect number is
and you can debate that I guess to some
extent but I've seen around maybe
$70,000 a years that perfect number
probably not yeah I know I've seen that
number as well and there's there that
also depends on how you word those
questions about self-reported life
satisfaction versus happiness and how is
that described etc here's another more
specific one sales jobs a lot of people
become victims of a type of recruiting
for sales jobs that call them something
else my brother actually had this
experience and I know a lot of people
who do they they don't consider
themselves to be salespeople and they
get roped into jobs that often have
other names like you will be an account
executive or you will be in charge of
business development or you will be a
there's a million names for it and at
the bottom line there's sales jobs that
are not for everybody and if people
realize that these are just sales jobs
and they are not sales type people they
would skip really a bad time that they
have in their lives so many people I
know have fallen to this it's sort of a
micro exam
bull but that's an example and also
procrastination many people fall victims
to procrastination in life there are
people who have attention deficit issues
learning disabilities different
particular circumstances that tend to
make them procrastinate I am talking
very generally about procrastination and
I've had periods of my life where that
this is also a problem for me my
strategy is to break tasks down into
component parts just try to get one
component part done right so I've got a
speaking gig coming up in about a month
and the task of putting together the
slides I want to bring to it and my
notes all at once it seems kind of big
in a very busy day where I'm doing the
show and teaching and have other
commitments so I split it up and I say
hey let me just come up with the title
for my talk and I do it the next day I
say let me just break the talk down into
the five areas I want to cover and I get
that done the next day I say I just want
to come up with my first few comments as
to how I'm going to start the talk and
before you know it I don't really feel
like I've buckled down and actually
started but I've got the title some
initial notes my outline and an
introduction and now I'm in actually
pretty good shape and sometimes the
hardest part of the job is just getting
yourself started right I mean once you
actually are in that mode in that zone
you just keep going often yeah yes I
find that with myself but not ever like
can we just talk about this later yeah
well this is a conversation we shouldn't
have right now I'm actually dealing with
this a lot in so I'm teaching at Boston
College and there's lots of discussions
among the faculty as to how can you
really prevent students from
procrastinating on major reports papers
tests studying for tests whatever and
Dan Ariely
has written a lot about in classes how
to prevent procrastination by students
and it's a pretty interesting topic in
and of itself okay great questions for
today I'm out of time but we've got a
great bonus show and I encourage you to
join us on the bonus show sign up get
access either by becoming a patreon
donor at patreon.com slash david pakman
show or a member at david pakman
komm slash membership